créeme no quieres tener estos logros en
tu perfil y es que a pesar de que la
mayoría de logros te felicitan por tu
esfuerzo estos otros solo buscan
ofenderte pero qué imbécil por ejemplo
en el juego Lollipop chaino se te
otorgará un logro si tratas de mirar por
debajo de la falda de la protagonista
cosa que casualmente también sucede near
automata Qué rico en el God of War
original si te parten la madre demasiado
el juego pensará que estás medio menso y
te ofrecerá a bajar la dificultad no sin
antes darte el logro llamado me están
pateando el trasero y en the other World
si no usas su mecánica de ralentizar el
tiempo para acabar con tus enemigos y en
su lugar la usas para dispararle a 30
enemigos en la entrepierna recibirás el
logro poca deportividad para que todo el
mundo sepa que peleas como niñita si
quieres ver más Pásate por mi canal Y
échale un vistazo al video completo con
más de 18 de los logros más ofensivos
que hay te espero